heute ist der Tag an dem die Regierung
den ersten Schritt macht um Haschisch
freizugeben also das Rauchen von
Cannabis in Zukunft zumindest in kleinen
Mengen erlaubt aus einer Droge wird dann
etwas ganz legales ja der
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach hat
dafür gesorgt dass sein haschischsplan
am Vormittag von der Regierung erstmal
beschlossen worden ist und gleich
erklärt Lauterbach uns diesen Hasch Plan
ganz genau sie sehen oben rechts schon
das Bild da wird er gleich aufkreuzen
und uns ganz genau informieren welche
Wenge ab wann und so weiter den Plan
kennt aber schon unsere bildreporterin
Nadja assfad tja der Gesundheitsminister
der jetzt zum haschischminister wird ist
das nicht irgendwie Widerspruch
hallo Kai da hast du vollkommen recht
das kann man in der Tat extrem
irritieren finden also es gibt ja schon
seit 2017 medizinisches Haschisch dass
man in der Apotheke kaufen kann wenn man
ein Rezept dafür besitzt die
Ampelkoalition hat sich fest vorgenommen
dieses Gesetz jetzt zu beschließen an
dieser Legislaturperiode hat das in den
Koalitionsvertrag aufgenommen fakt ist
aber auch Herr Lauterbach dass extrem
abgestürzt wir wissen er mag nicht so
sehr wie öffentliche Auftritte
gleichzeitig verheilen seine
corona-warnungen ungehört und es nimmt
auch keiner mehr so richtig ernst
deswegen ist das natürlich für ihn die
perfekte Bühne oder könnte es sein um
mal wieder ein bisschen Popularität zu
haben ein bisschen Aufmerksamkeit auf
sich zu ziehen und was zu diskutieren
klar gibt's aktuell gerade ganz andere
Probleme die viel ernster viel wichtiger
und viel dringender sind die Ampel hat
das nicht vorgenommen auch deswegen ist
es heute Thema warum ist Karl Lauterbach
so ein großer Befürworter davon diese
eigentlich illegale Droge zu
legalisieren
vollkommen berechtigte Frage er hat ja
selbst gestanden dass auch mal
ausprobiert zu haben und auch nicht
abgeneigt gewesen zu sein oder ist einer
der wenigen Politiker die zugegeben hat
dass er mal [ __ ] hätte
wir wissen auch aus einer Umfrage von
der Bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
Aufklärung das Cannabis tatsächlich die
beliebteste der illegalen Drogen ist
sowohl bei Jugendlichen als auch bei
Erwachsenen insofern und dadurch dass
eben das Thema im Koalitionsvertrag
festgeschrieben ist drängt es ein
bisschen und wir sehen auch hier hinter
mir in der Bundespressekonferenz wird
das jetzt immer voller und Herr
Lauterbach wird in den nächsten Minuten
erwarten ich weiß nicht ob er jetzt
vielleicht sogar schon mitgekommen ist
aber ich bin sehr gespannt auf das
Eckpunktepapier was er jetzt gleich
vorstellen wird ja da hören wir gleich
ganz genau zu mir geht die ganze Zeit
schon die Frage durch den Kopf was
passiert eigentlich mit den ganzen
Dealern zum Beispiel hier in Berlin am
Görlitzer parken und die man immer
laufen lässt wenn man sich immer wundert
warum macht er eigentlich niemand was
hier mitten in Berlin und holt die da
von der Straße sind die künftig
sozusagen ihren Job los
das kann man nur hoffen also falls
dieses Gesetz dann tatsächlich kommen
sollte kann man nur hoffen dass es zu
einer Entkriminalisierung führt und das
ist zumindest die Kriminellen dann
arbeitslos macht tatsächlich ist es aber
sehr sehr fraglich weil Leute die am
Görlitzer Platz spielen die Linie ja
nicht nur mit Haschisch die verkaufen
auch noch andere Sachen insofern ist die
Frage ob das wirklich für die große
Probleme bereitet viel schlimmer ist die
Gefahr dass Deutschland dann ein
Anziehungspunkt werden könnte für
Drogentourismus das ist eine Gefahr von
der waren zum Beispiel die Union immer
wieder Check der Gesundheitsminister in
Bayern ist hat das gestern noch mal sehr
deutlich gemacht also wir müssen mal
abwarten was da am Ende mal rum kommt
aber es gibt große Gefahren danke an
unsere bildreporterin Nadia aswart der
Gesundheitsminister hat gerade Platz
genommen sie haben es zu Hause schon
gesehen auf dem Bildschirm hat er geht
jetzt eben oben auch rein und wir hören
alle zu Karl Lauterbach wie er uns
erklärt warum und wie er künftig
Cannabis freigeben möchte hier bei uns
in Deutschland
Konferenz sind dann eingetragener Verein
von Hauptstadt JournalistInnen
Hauptstadt oder Journalisten und unsere
Aufgabe ist
Pressekonferenzen durchzuführen die für
unsere Mitglieder
von Interesse sind wir sind von der
Regierung unabhängig und ein Mitglied
des Vorstandes in diesem Falle ich
leitet diese PK hemminister sie haben
das Wort Liebe Frau wertig ich darf mich
zunächst einmal ganz herzlich bedanken
dafür dass wir erneut in Ihren
Räumlichkeiten auch unter ihrer Leitung
hier Tagen dürfen wir sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren das Bundeskabinett hat heute
Eckpunkte zur kontrollierten Abgabe von
Cannabis an Erwachsene zu genusszwecken
beschlossen
danach soll klargestellt werden was die
Voraussetzungen sein werden das künftig
straffrei Cannabis produziert werden
kann verkauft werden kann und wieder
Besitz zu regeln ist diese
eckpunktepapiere werde ich heute nicht
als großen Durchbruch in der
Drogenpolitik verkaufen weil es sind
jetzt zunächst einmal in einer Phase wo
wir prüfen ob die Grundlage die wir
heute geschaffen haben im Eck Klopapier
ob diese auch international insbesondere
nach Völkerrecht und europäischem Recht
tragfähig ist womit wir gehen hier ganz
ehrlich und offen an diese Debatte heran
zunächst einmal der Hintergrund ist der
Koalitionsvertrag und der inhaltliche
Hintergrund dessen was wir hier tun ist
wir wollen an der Entkriminalisierung
des Cannabiskonsums erwirken um damit
einen besseren Kinder und Jugendschutz
aber auch einen besseren
Gesundheitsschutz zu erreichen und somit
also den Problemen entgegenwirken die
wir feststellen bei der Bewertung der
derzeitigen Umgangsweise mit Cannabis
wir haben keine wirklich also
im vorzeigbaren Erfolge in den letzten
Jahren erzielen können der
Cannabiskonsum ist gestiegen der
THC-Gehalt des Cannabis ist eher auch
gestiegen der Jugendschutz ist wirklich
erfolgreich gewesen und wir haben zum
Teil auch mittlerweile durch bemgung und
dadurch so sehr hohe Konzentrationen im
Cannabis haben wir problematisches
Suchtverhalten sogar bei Erwachsenen
somit wenn man zusammenfasst wo stehen
wir jetzt was ist die Ausgangslage die
Ausgangslage ist die Kinder und
Jugendschutz sind nicht ausreichend
gewährleistet problematisches
konsumieren bei Erwachsenen wird
beobachtet die Tendenz ist also in geht
in die falsche Richtung und wir haben
darüber hinaus an florierenden
Schwarzmarkt der natürlich dann auch mit
Kriminalität einhergeht und das wiederum
bringt nicht nur große Kosten bei den
Ermittlern und bei den Gerichten sondern
führt auch dazu dass Menschen quasi
einen Teil ihrer Jugend vielleicht auch
in Teil ihres Lebens also verschlechtern
indem sie einfach in eine in einen Sog
der Kriminalität geraten was den Handel
angeht was den Konsum angeht was jetzt
angeht somit die Drogenpolitik muss
erneuert werden und wir gehen da wie
folgt vor das ist auch der Grund weshalb
ich federführend also für dieses Gesetz
hier heute mit ihnen diskutiere und
dafür auch stehe wir wollen also den
Cannabiskonsum unter Gesundheitsaspekten
reformieren es haben sich mehr als ein
Dutzend
Ressorts an der Entwicklung dieser
Eckpunkte beteiligt ich möchte daher den
beteiligten Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ganz herzlich danken aber im Vordergrund
steht der Gesundheitsschutz und der
Gesundheitsschutz ist auch das was wir
heute also diskutieren wir haben vier
Millionen Menschen dem letzten Jahr
Cannabis genutzt haben 25 Prozent der 18
bis so 24-Jährigen haben Cannabis
konsumiert wir haben eine Situation dass
also der
Substanzkonsum eher zunimmt und wir
haben keine wirklich guten Konzepte
daher solche folgendes erreicht werden
der Schwarzmarkt erfolgreich verdrängt
werden die also Entkriminalisierung soll
dazu beitragen dass also bis Anbau
Besitz und Konsum in den von uns
geregelten Grenzwerten stahlfrei bleiben
wir wollen erreichen dass der
Jugendschutz verstärkt wird dazu sollen
also nur bei Erwachsenen 20 bis 30 Gramm
begrenzter also kauf oder
Besitz strafrei gestellt werden wir
werden prüfen ob wir bei den unter
21-Jährigen Cannabis so regulieren dass
der THC-Gehalt eine Obergrenze beachten
muss das ist für die jetzige Vorlage
noch nicht so also vorgesehen dass
werden wir aber prüfen der also Vertrieb
und der Anbau sollen staatlich
kontrolliert werden das bedeutet wir
streben anders also der die gesamte
Menge die hier vertrieben und konsumiert
wird dass sie in Deutschland produziert
werden soll also wir wollen die
Produktion also in Deutschland
regulieren lizenzieren und auch
regulieren und wir wollen aus die Abgabe
Regeln durch lizenzierte Abgabestellen
in die prüfen ob in diesen Abgabestellen
also auch konsumiert werden darf das ist
zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt nicht vorgesehen
wir prüfen auch also ob wir andere
Darreichungsformen die über den normalen
also
Cannabiskonsum hinweggehen also die
übliche Darreichungsform die da wäre
also dabei also raucht aber Cannabis
oder Cannabis in Kapseln oder Sprays
angeboten wird ob darüber hinaus also
Angebote in sogenannten adiparts also
dieser amerikana bis Kuchen und
dergleichen angeboten wird dass es jetzt
nicht vorgesehen das wird geprüft und
wir prüfen auch also ob die gesamte
Regelungen die Ziele
erreichen kann die wir ja anstreben wie
wir vorgehen ich hatte eben schon also
angedeutet wir gehen damit ganz offen
und ehrlich vor insbesondere auch was
die Europäische Kommission angeht wir
werden diese Eckpunkte heute der
Europäischen Kommission zuleiten wir
werden dann darum bitten dass eine vorab
Prüfung stattfindet und diese
Vorabprüfung wird dann ergeben ob er ein
Vertragsverletzungsverfahren zu erwarten
haben wenn eine solche Vorabprüfung klar
ergeben würde dass dieser Weg für die
Europäische Kommission nicht gangbar ist
dann würden wir auf dieser Grundlage
auch keinen Gesetzentwurf entwickeln
also was wir nicht wollen ist eine
Hängepartie oder ein kompliziertes
Verfahren was es beispielsweise im
Verkehrsrecht in Deutschland schon
einmal gegeben hat wir wollen eine ganz
klare also Ansage machen das ist der das
ist die Zielrichtung dessen was wir
wollen so glauben wir dass wir dies
erreichen dass im Rahmen einer
sogenannten interpretationslösung dann
vorgetragen sehr stark vereinfacht
ausgedrückt ist es auch durch die
völkerrechtlichen Verträge und die
EU-Verträge verboten Cannabis also in
den Verkehr zu bringen weil damit also
Gesundheitsschäden einhergehen und auch
Kriminalität entstehen kann und wir
interpretieren die bestehenden Verträge
so dass wir sagen wenn man diese
Entkriminalisierung so vornimmt wie wir
es vortragen dann wird damit dem
Anliegen dieser Verträge mehr Rechnungen
getragen weil wir damit die
Entkriminalisierung aber auch den Schutz
der Bevölkerung in Bezug auf
Gesundheitsgefährdung aber auch Kinder
und Jugendschutz besser gerecht werden
also dass man den man dem besser gerecht
wird dass wenn das nicht tut wie
interpretieren den Inhalt der
bestehenden Verträge so dass das Ziel
der bestehenden Verträge mit unserem
Ansatz besser verfolgt werden kann das
ist die sogenannte Interpretation
Auslösung und die tragen wir ab heute
der Europäischen Kommission vor und
erwarten uns eine schnelle Rückmeldung
und davon wird dann auch abhängen also
ob wir das ganze so verfolgen dass es
einen Gesetzentwurf geben wird
vielleicht so viel als kurze Einführung
von meiner Seite vielen Dank ich habe
schon eine ganze Reihe von Fragen von
Wortmeldungen vorliegen eine Frage bitte
eine Nachfrage und wenn sie sich kurz
vorstellen wir fangen auf der von uns
aus gesehenen linken Seite an bitteschön
sie hatten sich gemeldet ja
aus den Niederlanden
Journalist für die Telegraf in den
Niederlanden gibt es diese Abgabe
natürlich schon länger und damit hat man
gemischte Erfahrungen gemacht über viele
Jahre Jahrzehnte meine Frage ist ob sie
mit niederländischen Kollegen oder aus
den Ressorts ob da Abstimmungen oder ja
einfach Austausch gewesen ist über diese
jahrzehntelange Erfahrung um die
Erfahrungen positiv negativ waren und ja
weil es zum Beispiel diese Delegationen
aus Amsterdam aus Rotterdam größere
Städte wo es viele Coffeeshops gibt die
fahren ständig nach Berlin die tauschen
sich mit den deutschen Beamten aus also
die Erfahrungen auch ihre
Lagebericht quasi so eingeflossen sind
und
stimmt es dass sie auch selber schon mal
Cannabis geraucht haben dass ein guter
Arzt so etwas
ausprobieren soll
wir tauschen uns mit den Kolleginnen und
Kollegen aus den Niederlanden sehr eng
aus und
beurteilen also die dortige Form der
Regulierung als also nicht
erfolgreich in dem Sinne dass wir das
niederländische moderne nachahmen wollen
und ihr den Niederlanden ist ja im
Prinzip die Straffreiheit einhergegangen
mit einem wenig regulierten Markt so
dass man wenn man also ist etwas
überspitzt ausdrückt dort die Nachteile
miteinander kommen kombiniert man hat
also quasi einen liberal an der
Liberalen Nutzung aber keinen
kontrollierten Markt und das wollen wir
eben nicht sondern wir wollen auch auf
der Grundlage der Erfahrung in den
Niederlanden den Markt also sehr also
streng regulierend Anbau regulieren
Qualität regulieren Abgabe regulieren
sicherstellen dass also der Abgabe nicht
an Jugendliche Erfolg an kindererfolgt
entsprechende Strafen sind da ja vor
sehen somit wollen wir den gesamten
Markt kontrollieren abgab Produktion
Abgabe Lieferung aber auch Nutzung und
wenn man quasi nur die mit der
strafreiheit kommt aber die Produktion
die Nutzung vollkommen also unreguliert
lässt dann ist aus meiner Sicht das also
Verfahren nicht erfolgreich und daher
haben wir aus den niederländischen
Erfahrungen also gelernt dass wir so
nicht machen wollen muss einfach
auszudrücken zum zweiten also was ein
guter Arzt zu tun hat das kann ich nicht
kommentieren ich kann nur sagen dass ich
tatsächlich schon einmal probeweise
konsumiert habe das habe ich auch
öffentlich gemacht ich bin aber kein
Nutzer und würde von der Regulierung
hier auch nicht profitieren weil ich nur
einen probekonsum hier vorzuweisen hätte
der Unterschied jetzt kurz vorstellen
zur portugiesischen Lösung
da der portugiesischen Lösung sind die
Regeln wie produziert wird also wo
produziert werden kann wie die also Fach
also wieder fachnachweis also zu
erbringen ist anders geregelt als wir
das also vorsehen und bei uns sind zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt auch viele Fragen
noch nicht also geklärt zum Beispiel
klären wir noch also ob ein THC-Gehalt
als Obergrenze bei den bis zu 21 Jahre
alten eingezogen werden soll oder nicht
wir prüfen noch ob also edibles
zugelassen sein sollen oder noch oder
nicht da sind noch sehr viele Dinge die
wir offen lassen wo wir auch auf das
Ergebnis der Vorprüfung durch die
Kommission reagieren wollen aber nicht
desto trotz also der portugiesische
Markt hat eine Ähnlichkeit und zwar das
eben dort sehr viel mit Aufklärung
gearbeitet wird und diese
aufklärungspunkt betrifft bei uns zum
Beispiel auch die jungen Menschen die
jetzt konsumieren obwohl es dann
strafreiheit ist aber den jungen
Menschen ich will mal so sagen was für
mich hier im Vordergrund steht ich war
sehr viele Jahre war ich also der
Legalisierung von Cannabis in
Deutschland ablehnend gegenüber
eingestellt ich habe meine eigene
Position erst in den letzten anderthalb
Jahren verändert und das auf der
Grundlage der also Bewertung wie
erfolgreich sind wir denn mit dem was
wir bisher machen und was wir bisher
machen ist nicht besonders erfolgreich
und einige Ansätze die in Portugal
gemacht werden insbesondere also
Aufklärung Kontrolle und so weiter finde
ich wirklich sind für uns interessant
die werden wir aufgreifen dennoch ist
das Gesamtkonzept ein anderes sie
sprachen gar nicht ihre eigene Haltung
zu Legalisierung an es ist jetzt aber
keine Legalisierung warum macht man
keine Legalisierung
es ist schon also für die über
18-Jährigen ist es dann eine
Legalisierung für die über 18-Jährigen
sind ja im Rahmen der Grenzen die ich
hier gerade beschrieben habe sind also
kauf Nutzung und Besitz also sind legal
einschließlich dem
aneigenanbau von bis zu drei Pflanzen
das ist dann legal in dem Sie innerhalb
dieser Grenzen
das ist straffrei nach dem
Betäubungsmittelgesetz
sondern Legalisierung es ist keine
komplett Legalisierung sondern es sind
enge Grenzen gesetzt aber es ist eine
Legalisierung es kommt dann nicht mehr
es ist dann nicht mehr Teil des
Betäubungsmittelgesetzes
eine Lernfrage ist dieses Nachfragen bei
der EU-Kommission ein offizielles
Notifizierungsverfahren und ist das in
diesem Fall tatsächlich zwingend
notwendig oder machen sie das sozusagen
um sich also freiwillig um sich
abzusichern also ein
Notifizierungsverfahren werden dem
Moment notwendig wenn wir mit einem
Gesetzentwurf ins Kabinett gehen dann
müssten wir vorher das
Notifizierungsverfahren
einschalten aber was ich einfach machen
möchte ich möchte einfach mit offenen
Karten klare Verhältnisse schaffen und
daher diese Vorprüfung auf der Grundlage
der Eckpunkte wir werden also dann auch
im Gespräch mit der Europäischen
Kommission also
abklopfen also ob man unserem Weg hier
bereit ist zu folgen wenn dieses Gesetz
so käme wäre das liberaler dies das
liberals auf der einen Seite das
liberalste Cannabis
legalisierungsprojekt in Europa auf der
anderen Seite wäre es aber auch das am
am stärksten regulierter Markt mit der
klaren Zielsetzung
Entkriminalisierung und besserer Jugend
und Gesundheitsschutz somit ist das in
vielerlei Hinsicht also ein Modell das
könnte ein Modell für Europa sein unsere
These ist einfach dass die Ziele der
europäischen Verträge und der
un-verträge mit einer solchen
Vorgehensweise besser umgesetzt werden
können das ist unser these darüber
werden wir mit der Kommission reden
folgt uns die Kommission
in diesem Ansatz dann kommt ein
Gesetzentwurf und der hätte dann die
Notifizierung Voraussetzung aber jetzt
gehen wir einfach in ein offenes und
dialogisches Verfahren und ich glaube
wir haben hier wirklich ein Angebot zu
machen weil es ist ja auch in anderen
Ländern das gleiche Problem zu
beobachten dass der Cannabiskonsum und
auch der Cannabiskonsum als
Einstiegsdroge das Problem ist ja
nirgendwo wirklich gut gelöst und ich
glaube dass dieser Weg daher auch für
andere europäische Länder interessant
sein könnte Zusatz bitte am Ende schützt
sie ein mögliches positives Votum der
Kommission ja aber nicht vor so einem
Desaster wie bei der Maut weil
Deutschland ja dann immer noch von
Mitgliedstaaten vor dem EuGH verklagt
werden kann also warum dann diese
Vorprüfung also
den mautvorgang möchte ich nicht
kommentieren aber so gehen wir definitiv
nicht vor wenn wir diese Vorprüfungen
bekommen und die Vorprüfung ist ein ist
also eindeutig entweder eindeutig
positive oder eindeutig negativ also ist
die Sache ja sowieso klar dann werden
wir wenn es eindeutig negativ ist wird
es also auf der Grundlage gar kein
Gesetzentwurf geben dann kann also so
etwas wie bei der Maut niemals passieren
es ist eindeutig positiv dann ist nicht
damit zu rechnen dass uns überhaupt also
ein Vertragsverletzungsverfahren droht
das sind die beiden idealpositionen oder
nicht idealpositionen sondern also sagen
wir die Pole die beiden Pole wenn es
jetzt so ist dass wir eine also
Rückmeldung bekommen da gehen wir mit
und das könnte problematisch werden dann
passen wir uns an
und ich glaube dass wir daher gut
vorbereitet sind ich halte daher eine
Hängepartie also wie bei der Maut für
vollkommen ausgeschlossen weil wir
werden sehr klar die Signale
interpretieren und gehen dann entweder
mit einem veränderten Entwurf rein oder
aber wir also müssen auf der Grundlage
dann den Rückzug antreten dann wird aber
auf dieser Grundlage kein Gesetzentwurf
entstehen
und der Kollege dahinter
ja Dominik neue Berliner
redaktionsgesellschaft
vergangene Woche hieß es aus ihrem
Ministerium noch was bestehen enorm
Erklärungsbedarf das Kabinett werde sich
in der kommenden Woche nicht damit
beschäftigen jetzt stehen sie hier vor
uns und stellen es vor was hat sich denn
in der Woche geändert und was hat sich
klären lassen in der kurzen Zeit
ja wir haben also sehr intensiv an dem
Gesetz also an den Eckpunkten gearbeitet
an der gesetzkultur gearbeitet und im
Rahmen dieser intensiven Beschäftigung
konnten viele Probleme ausgeräumt werden
ich bin um Verständnis dass ich da jetzt
nicht also durchgehen möchte was alles
stetig stand aber ist ein großes Gesetz
ich hatte schon darauf hingewiesen ich
bin also was Gesetzgebung angeht
einigermaßen Erfahrung erfahren weil ich
mit Gesetzgebung schon sehr viel
zusammen erfahrungssammeln konnte bevor
ich Minister wurde und es gab es gibt
wenige also Eckpunkte an die ich mich
erinnere die ähnlich also Komplex in der
Vorbereitung gewesen sind hier ist man
ja vom Verkehrsministerium über
Justizministerium übers Innenministerium
über das BMW also über das also bmwk
über also das Arbeitsministerium ist mit
landwirtschaftsmission ist man ja mit
fast jedem Ressort in Austausch daher
also ist es keine Übertreibung wenn ich
sage dass die Vorbereitung dieser
Eckpunkte sehr komplex gewesen ist das
ist wirklich also ausgesprochen komplex
gewesen daher wäre es denkbar gewesen
dass wir es bei dieser
kabinettsbefassung nicht geschafft
hätten aber das war dann doch so und
darum bin ich heute hier okay ja
Nachfrage
in dem letzte Woche veröffentlichten bzw
durchgestochenen Papier waren ja 20% 20
Gramm Besitz jetzt haben sie vorher also
es heißt es sowieso 20 bis 30 Gramm und
sie haben jetzt vorher kurz gesagt Kauf
und besitzt also das wäre ein großer
Unterschied ist es jetzt also die 20 bis
30 das wird noch geklärt aber ist es
jetzt kauf oder besitzt nein 20 bis 30
Gramm wird nicht geklärt sondern 20 bis
30 Gramm ist hier die Größenordnung mit
der wir die Kommission konfrontieren da
gibt es jetzt keinen Klärungsbedarf
sondern es sind 20 bis 30 Gramm sie
wissen selbst also oder möglicherweise
wissen Sie wie schwer es ist also die
genaue sagen wir das genaue Gewicht zu
bestimmen
und die Größenordnung ist daher klar und
ja es geht also um alle drei Komponenten
neben Produktion
Kauf und Besitz
hat Jessen freier Journalist Lauterbach
eine Frage zum Anbau drei Pflanzen drei
weibliche Pflanzen sollen legal sein die
können je nach Bedingungen mehrere 100
Gramm Ertrag bringen wir wollen Sie
sicherstellen dass der Eigentümer und
Besitzer der Pflanzen damit der
Besitzers Ertrages bei dieser Menge
nicht in Konflikt gerät mit den
Obergrenzen des Besitzes die sie eben
genannt haben
naja die Obergrenze des Besitzes für den
Kauf und für den Besitz gekauften
Produktes ist zu unterscheiden von dem
Besitz der sich ergibt durch die
erlaubte Nutzung der eigenen Pflanzen
von daher das also sind zwei
unterschiedliche wenn man so will
Tatbestände die dann auch rechtlich
anders zu prüfen sind wenn wir also bis
zu drei Pflanzen erlauben dann ist das
die Lage wenn jetzt dort tatsächlich
also getrickst würde meinetwegen es geht
dann demnächst super Pflanzen die ganze
Räume füllen dann würden wir hier
Nacharbeiten aber ich bitte einfach also
sagen wir zur Kenntnis zu nehmen dass
wir uns hier also sehr gut beraten haben
mit also der Szene die also für Anbau
Verkauf besitzt und so weiter und so
fort
ertragreiche Informationen geben kann
das haben wir also als einfließen lassen
da ist das eine pragmatische Lösung mit
der man gut arbeiten kann ertragreiche
Informationen ist ein hübscher Begriff
zweite Frage also Karl Lauterbach der
hier sein haschischsplan erstmal
vorgestellt hat kleine Mengen an
Cannabis werden straffrei künftig bei
uns in Deutschland also legal bis zu 30
Gramm gleichzeitig war das was wir da
gerade gesehen haben von Lauterbach aber
schon auch eine Warnung wieder er will
diese Freigabe von Haschisch nur unter
sehr sehr strengen Vorgaben das ist
gerade klar geworden sehr stark
reglementiert Deutschland wird also
nicht zum neuen Holland sagt lauterbach
[Musik]